[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the new hogwarts legacy game
which was recently announced the
official trailer for hogwarts legacy
was released on the playstation youtube
channel five days ago
and if you haven't seen it yet well
you're missing out while the trailer is
only two and a half minutes long
this is the first shred of new harry
potter content that we've had
in a very long time and it certainly got
people excited
the game is definitely long overdue and
people have been speculating about its
release
for years though no official statement
had ever been released by warner
brothers
great so a new harry potter game but
what kind of game is it we've had harry
potter games in the past
how is this any different a press
release from this week
confirmed that it is in fact an open
world
single player action role playing game
which will allow you to create your own
personal witch or wizard
and spec them exactly as you want them
to be players will experience
life as a student at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
like never before as they live the
unwritten and embark on a dangerous
journey
to uncover a hidden truth of the
wizarding world they will grow their
characters abilities
as they master powerful spells hone
combat skills
and select companions to help them face
off against deadly enemies
players will also encounter missions and
scenarios that will pose difficult
choices
and determine what they stand for
additionally this game is clearly the
product of a great deal of effort
something which i can't say for some of
the harry potter themed games
that have been released in the past this
game has been in the works for a while
and i predict that it's going to set
itself apart from the rest
with innovative high definition graphics
a player can practically feel the terror
of inferi
bearing down upon them sense the ground
rumbling beneath them
as a heard of angry centaurs surrounds
them even dueling against a deadly dark
witch
takes on a new level of realism thanks
to the controller's ability to imbue
sound and touch
into every moment the clear forethought
and effort that appears to have been
placed on this game
makes things seem promising and the
prospect of an open world harry potter
game
has got me excited but what's it all
about
is it canon does it touch on the lives
of the existing characters that we know
and love
or is it something else altogether the
game created by portkey games and
avalanche software
takes place around 100 years before
harry potter starts attending hogwarts
you'll play as a student attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
during the late 1800s and just like any
other student at hogwarts
you'll attend classes and learn magic
alongside your classmates
you have received late acceptance to the
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
and soon discover that you are no
ordinary student
you possess an unusual ability to
perceive and master
ancient magic even more exciting it
looks as though you will be able to
determine your own path
good or evil much like star wars knights
of the old republic
kotor was one of my favorite games of
all time and if harry potter legacy is
able to live up to that game
at all then i'll be satisfied only you
can decide if you'll protect this secret
for the good of all or yield to the
temptation of more sinister magic
okay so the game takes place in the late
1800s
which technically means that since we're
going to be attending hogwarts
we should see some familiar faces
there's also one man in particular
that i'm hoping to see that was quite
important in the harry potter franchise
albus dumbledore ever heard of him
dumbledore was born in the year 1881
and he started attending hogwarts in the
year 1892.
if the game takes place in the late
1800s i'm going to assume that this
covers the 1880s
and 1890s so will we see our beloved
hogwarts headmaster
according to avalanche software and
portkey games who are responsible for
hogwarts legacy
the game will follow the wizarding world
law set out in the original harry potter
novels
however the story for the game itself is
entirely original
and was written by the studio not by jk
rowling
what this means is that we might not see
so many familiar faces
as it follows a different trajectory
altogether however
given that the studio have expressed
that the game will follow the wizarding
law set out in the novels
i think that it would be unusual for
dumbledore to not make an appearance
as he was quite a prominent figure at
the school during his schoolboy days
if he doesn't make an appearance at all
then i think that it would break canon
to some extent
i also think that everyone would be a
bit disappointed it would have been easy
for them to have simply set the game in
the 1850s or
1860s so i think that they must have
consciously chosen the late
1800s for a reason dumbledore went there
from 1892
to 1899 coincidence i think not
if dumbledore is included in the game i
am eager to see
how hogwarts legacy will portray him
particularly as at this point in his
life
he's not the wise old man that we've all
become accustomed to at this stage in
his life
dumbledore had not yet graduated which
means that he had not yet returned to
godric's hollow
which is where he met gellert
grindelwald when dumbledore met
grindelwald
it was a time of his life when he went
down a much darker path
dumbledore didn't have all the answers
and he was still figuring things out for
himself
so given that his time at school
predates this period i can only
speculate the school boy dumbledore
would be even more naive there has been
some speculation by fans that
if dumbledore is present in the game
that he will have some kind of direct
affiliation with the character that we
play
the most popular idea floating around is
that our character will serve as some
sort of a mentor or teacher to
dumbledore
helping him to develop the strong
personality that he has later in life
others have speculated that our
character will actually be dumbledore's
rival
a bully that treats dumbledore the same
way that draco treated harry
or james potter treated snape given that
the game has alluded to freedom
with regards to the moral path that our
character can go down perhaps both of
these will be options
either way it will be interesting to see
a younger
teenage dumbledore as in both the
fantastic beasts and harry potter films
he already seems to have figured
everything out more than everyone else
the headmaster of hogwarts during this
time according to canon
is phineas nigellus black who served as
headmaster from 1847
to 1925. phineas was a pure blood member
of slytherin house
and perhaps the most hated hogwarts head
master in the school's history
despite his notoriety phineas was
immortalized in the form of a portrait
in the headmaster's office
and he has some back and forth with
harry in the order of the phoenix
i thought that to belong in gryffindor
house you were supposed to be brave
it looks to me as i would have been
better off in my own house
we slytherins are brave yes but not
stupid
for instance given the choice we will
always choose to save our own necks
it's not my own neck i'm saving oh i see
this is no cowardly flight
you're being noble if portkey and
avalanche have decided to place familiar
characters in the game
which do you expect to see which
characters do you know
that were at hogwarts in the late 1800s
we still don't know exactly how the
gameplay will work just yet
but the trailer certainly gives us a bit
of an idea and i expected in the months
to come
more and more information will be
revealed to us about how the game itself
will operate
we also don't have an exact release date
for the game just yet
but we do know that it's coming out in
2021 which is certainly making 2021
look a lot better than 2020 already
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of this game
are you going to play it which
characters do you hope to see in it let
me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you